bravo merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors la france
insoumise votre camp et jean luc
mélenchon donc décidé de ne pas se
rendre à cette marche
contrairement à d'autres personnalités
de gauche comme yannick jadot ou encore
fabien roussel
pourquoi vous ne participez pas cette
marche des policiers aujourd'hui à
écouter je regardais déjà vos images je
regardais la violence et l'agressivité
de monsieur darmanin vous avez déjà un
début d'explication
et puis pour parler de monsieur jadot
monsieur jeannot il va en son nom propre
parce que europe écologie les verts a
annoncé aussi asseoir qu'il ne
participerait pas en tant que mouvement
politique non plus à cette manifestation
à l'ennui sont pas pourquoi parce que
c'est un rassemblement revendicatif sous
couvert dommage lorsqu il y à des
hommages légitime fonctionnaires de
police tombé lors de l'exercice de leurs
missions non député citoyens un membre
de la france en soliste nous sommes
toujours là pour rendre ces hommages
légitime aux gens qui vous protège mais
là c'est un rassemblement revendicatif
et donc sur l'assemblement revendicatif
pose des items contre lequel nous sommes
puis il ya ce phénomène d'
instrumentalisation et nous respectons
d'être ni la police des fois je vous
interromps désolé vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec certaines des
revendications des polices rassemble
aujourd'hui à certaines quasiment tout
c'est à dire que là nous avons une
surenchère sécuritaire après la sécurité
globale
là ils ne sont plus de prison le
durcissement des peines contre ce qu'ils
sentent un policier mais le code pénal
prévoit déjà ceux ci un pisteur le
meurtre d'un fonctionnaire de police est
puni de la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité alors aussi je vois pas ce
qu'il ya et puis surtout surtout la
suppression de tous les dispositifs qui
concourent à la prévention de la
récidive
je pense d'eux
1 a publié que sur le volet répressif et
une erreur il faut de la répression à
une certaine dose mais si on oublie la
prévention sur les causes de la
délinquance je crois que c'est une
énorme erreur
alors moi je pense que c'est là l'une
des raisons aussi qui pousse les forces
de l'ordre à se rassembler aujourd'hui
c'est qu'ils ont le sentiment elles ont
le sentiment justement de ne pas être
elle même en sécurité alors qu'elles
sont censées assurer la sécurité des
français ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça vous sentez une magie de la sécurité
de devises avis justement des forces de
l'ordre je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça mais les solutions qui sont
proposées
la solution ce n'est pas une opération
d'intimidation de la justice c'est bah
c'est qu'il faut faire vous avez là
d'ailleurs deux ministres qui vont
participer à l'assemblée regarder la
chose d'ubuesque voir kafkaïenne c'est à
dire que vous allez avoir un ministre de
la justice et un ministre de l'intérieur
qui vont devenir devant la chambre des
députés c'est-à-dire que l'exécutif va a
menacé mais enfin on va essayer de faire
pression sur le législatif c'est déjà
très anti républicain et puis le
ministre
donc va faire pression contre lui même
on ne comprend pas du tout ceci est par
contre
et vous avez raison la police non plus
de protection et à la raison mais pour
ça il ya des solutions il faut recréer
une police de proximité nous avons des
propositions
il faut renforcer la police judiciaire
pour démanteler les réseaux notamment
déjà payant si les heures
supplémentaires
il faut un plan de rénovation des
commissaires ils sont si de nouvelles
cibles il faut passer la formation à
deux ans il faut valoriser les agents
administratifs et scientifique
voyez on a beaucoup de propositions acer
vous prenez par exemple des gens qui
sont dans la manifestation de droite et
de droite extrême et bien sous le
gouvernement n'ait gouvernement de
sarkozy dit il
sanction jamais de position été
supprimés voyez donc c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va essayer de sécuriser le
parcours des fonctionnaires
les syndicalistes dénoncent le laxisme
aussi de la justice en france
eh bien je crois que ça c'est une erreur
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous ne
sommes pas là ça fait partie des heureux
des revendications contre lesquelles
nous sommes je ne vois pas l'intérêt de
faire pression je ne vois pas l'intérêt
que la police fasse pression sur la
justice
la problématique est la problématique
elle est ailleurs et les solutions qui
sont peut-être dans celle que je viens
de dénoncer voyez ce que je veux dire
alors oui elle est non mais voilà donc à
partir de ce moment il ya plusieurs
facettes qui nous pousse à ne pas
participer à cette à cette manifestation
les revendications parce que c'est une
manifestation revendicative
et puis le reste est de la police le
reste est de la police et donc nous ne
participons pas à l'instrumentalisation
qui en est fait depuis partie
l'instrumentalisation qui en fait que
par exemple d'après vous bien le
ministre de l'intérieur qui participent
à cette manifestation et est ce que vous
craignez aussi les débordements cet
après midi sur l'instrumentalisation
vous avez le front national qui sera à
côté de darmanin et dames 1 qui avait
trouvé d'ailleurs madame le pen trop
molle et depuis la droite et la droite
extrême qui vont effectivement
instrumentaliser le malheur que vivent
certains fonctionnaires de police et le
malheur extrêmes c'est-à-dire
effectivement le la mort de certains
fonctionnaires de police sont réalisés
par ces gens là et ça c'est dramatique
je pense qu'il faut avoir un peu plus de
respect pour l'institution policière
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont eu en fait on est
dans une démarche politique nous nous
sommes dans une démarche de résolution
effectivement de la problématique de ce
service public qui parti nous
désapprouvons de tous les services
publics et particulièrement là aussi je
ne la police merci beaucoup à vous
michel larive d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
député de la france insoumise de
l'ariège